Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here and, uh,
today I want to talk about how to study
effectively, not just how to learn
languages, but how to study effectively.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell to get notifications.
Uh, I, I'd like to do actually
a series of four videos.
Uh, I'd like to talk about how to study
effectively based on my experience
in learning languages, what I've read
about learning languages, what I've
read about how the brain works, what I
remember from when I was at school, uh,
some of the things that I think language
instruction does that is not successful
in schools and why the same unsuccessful
method is used to teach other subjects,
causing a lot of frustration for people.
So, first of all, today, I'm
simply going to talk about how
to study effectively in general.
And then in the second in the
series, I hope to do a series of
four actually, in the second series
I'll talk about why I think language
instruction in schools is not effective.
Then in the third in the series, I want to
talk about, you know, learning in a month
or, you know, uh, how to learn quickly
and all of the different hints and tips
and hacks that are offered on the internet
for how to learn languages quickly.
My views on these, and again, tying it all
back to studying effectively in general.
And then in the final one, I'm
going to talk about learning
a language from scratch.
So again, applying the sort of principles
of effective study to, uh, you know,
learning a language from scratch.
So, um, I'm not going to talk
about specifically language
learning or about LingQ.
People complain that I mention
LingQ, although  I love LingQ and
that's  where I learn languages.
And what we do at LingQ in a sense as a
reflection of my view of how we learn.
Uh, but I'm going to talk about learning.
And study...
effective study in general.
All right.
First of all, the first thing I think
we need to do to study effectively
is to improve our reading skills.
If we aren't good readers, we need to
become good readers to read faster,
to get better at acquiring information
through reading, because reading
is very effective, very efficient.
It enables us to access so much
information, whether in, you know, a paper
type of book, a traditional book or an
ebook where we can, you know, look things
up if we're on a niPad or on a computer.
Being careful to be, you know, to
avoid the distractions granted.
So reading is super powerful.
Uh, also get used to listening.
Uh, again, listening is something
that we can do wherever we are.
We can enjoy the voice
of the person explaining.
I find reading and listening
more effective than video because
with video, we are captive.
Video can be part of a study plan.
It can be fun to watch video.
It's sometimes possible to
explain things via video in a
way that we can't in a book.
So I think you need a
combination of all three.
So when we talk about combining
reading, listening, and video,
We're talking about combining.
And I think combining it's
a big part of learning.
Um, I found that in learning languages,
but not only in learning languages, in
learning other subjects, I have to sort
of get at the, whatever I was trying
to learn using different approaches,
different books, different resources.
Don't just try to memorize the textbook.
You, you have to try and force
yourself to go out and find other
resources that cover the same material.
Uh, and that's why we combine video
with listening with audio, with, uh,
with reading, because the brain, the
way the brain works is the brain is not
very good at sort of aceing something
now, learning some specific bits of
knowledge or facts, or even, uh, you
know, some, a mathematical equation.
These are things that we kind
of learn them and there's,
it's difficult for the brain.
You know, again, I'm not
a neuroscientist, but.
They go into the hippocampus and they
don't stay there very long, but the
strength of the brain is its ability
to sort of start to identify patterns.
And that's why we have to be patient
and keep feeding the brain, you know,
the same kind, you know, I've referred
to it as grazing and interleaving, some
of the same material interspersed with
going off and doing something else and
then coming back and reading about this
or in some other format so that this
combination learning, grazing learning is
according to research, much more effective
than trying to nail something down.
And, uh, that's why it's, it's so
counterproductive in the school
system where they teach you something,
and now, because they've taught it to
you, therefore they think you should be
able to reproduce it or be tested on it.
And of course you can't.
So you only get six out of
10, which is frustrating.
As a learner, we have to remember
that however difficult something
may seem, uh, whether it be a
language or a concept in mathematics
or in science or anything else,
in time, the brain will develop a
pattern that enables us to grasp the
concept better and better slowly.
The emphasis is on slowly it and
the Manfred Spitzer, whom I always
quote, he says, you know, the brain
can't do otherwise than learn.
The brain will gradually learn,
create patterns to deal with.
All the stimulus and, and
information that's coming at it.
It'll drop some of the details,
but it'll start forming a pattern.
And when you have this pattern in your
brain, it becomes easier then to remember
some of the details, because you have
a context, the brain has created this,
this, uh, network of, of, uh, patterns
that makes it then easier to learn.
So it's very important not to be
frustrated if we read this explanation
five times and it still doesn't make
sense, or we keep forgetting things.
And of course we get six out
of 10 or three out of 10 on
the test and we shouldn't allow
ourselves to be discouraged.
Of course the education
system is set up that way.
It's set up that way because for
whatever reason, the people in charge
of education feel that they have to
test you at every step of the way to
make sure you're learning something.
In reality, what was taught yesterday
may not click in for another six months.
So it's kind of meaningless to test
us immediately on, on what's in our
short term memory, for example, rather
we should, you know, as teachers
encourage learners to cover the same
ground using different materials
and we as learners should resist
this sort of sense of frustration that we
can't understand, that we can't remember
it, we can't do it, it doesn't make sense.
We have to continue.
And that's again, always, I go
back to this idea of combining
things, watch a video by all means,
but then also if you can find...
and in the case of science and math you
have Khan Academy, which is tremendous,
but you should have still at the same
time, work on your reading, work on
reading explanations of the same thing.
Again, without that sense of, you
know, frustration or fear as you're
not, still not able to remember
or grasp at all, just keep going.
It's slowly going to sock into place.
Just the way languages
slowly sock into place.
And, you know, work on all the different
aspects of your brain, including
the emotional side of your brain.
So if you can listen to something that's
pleasant, where you enjoy the voice,
if you don't like listening to your
professor, but if you can find some other
audio, which is more interesting or where
you enjoy the voice, listen to that, but
you still have to go back and read or
listen to what the professor had to say.
Cause you gotta, you gotta,
you know, write the exam.
And most professors like to have
things come back to them the way
they, they, uh, you know, taught it.
But, so, so as, as, as a general
principle in, in learning, I think all
of the things that I say about language
learning, when I think back, you know,
when I did well in a subject it's because
I got interested in the subject, I read
up on it using different resources.
Um, and, and so, and the other thing too
is as with language learning, of course,
it's good to talk and exchange views
about a subject that you're learning and
to talk to the other people in the class
and to talk to the teacher and so forth.
But you have to have something in
you before you can talk about the
subject just as with language,
you can't begin by speaking.
You have to begin by allowing
your brain to get used to it.
And that's where the reading and the
listening primarily, and to some extent
video is kind of the prerequisite.
And once you've got some of those patterns
in your brain, then yeah, the more you
can talk about it and do experiments
and do things and activate some of these
things that you have brought into your
brain, the better you're going to do it.
So that's sort of a general discussion
on how to study effectively.
Uh, the big message is to my mind
is don't allow yourself to get
frustrated, get hung up at your
mistakes or perhaps your, your results
on a test or things that you forget.
Try to find a way to get
interested in, in the subject.
Uh, and that may mean that
your textbook is boring.
Find some other materials.
And graze around and cover the
same ground in different ways.
And I think that's an
effective way to study.